but not hot water with Nancy Pelosi
right I mean she told us earlier this
week in a Washington Post interview that
she's not too worried about impeachment
Trump's not worth it
here's her exact quote here impeachment
is so divisive to the country that
unless there's something so compelling
and overwhelming and bipartisan I don't
think we should go down that path
because it divides the country and he's
just not worth it there's two possible
scenarios here with Nancy Pelosi
statement first of all she could be
playing that three-dimensional chess we
hear so much about and maybe wants to
throw Trump off the scent and say no no
impeachment silly nonsense right we're
not gonna go that path don't worry about
that Trump you know essentially lulling
him into this false sense of security so
that he doesn't do something rash like
fire Robert Muller or you know start
questioning people in the DOJ pulling
them in front of the Oval Office desk
and saying tell me what you know yeah
maybe she's just trying to say no no no
don't worry we're not gonna impeach you
just go watch Fox News everything's cool
or she could be being honest and like
I'm gonna peach the guy it's not worth
it why bother why pay attention to the
majority of people in this country who
say maybe this is the route we need to
go why bother with all the crimes that
are already on the table cuz nobody
cares about those certainly not the
Republicans in the Senate so it's not
even like we could vote to remove him
from office so what's the point the
point is law and order
the point is checks and balances I know
there there's no part of me that doesn't
understand this we're not going to
remove Trump from office right there is
nothing I believe that could come out
even from the Muller report that would
convince enough Republicans in the
Senate to vote to kick him out of office
even if the Muller report contains
photographs of Donald Trump sitting down
with Vladimir Putin while holding a sign
that says I'm colluding with
to steal the 2016 election you're still
not gonna get enough Republicans they
love him because he's doing everything
they've wanted a Republican president to
do for a long time yeah they may not
always agree with his delivery or the
way he acts
but policy wise he is right on board
with them so it's never gonna happen
so does that mean we never try no it
does not
the people in this country wants some
answers about a lot of the things that
have happened they want to know that
Congress still has enough courage to
stand up to the executive branch we have
three branches of government and they're
all supposed to be equal and they're all
checks and balances on one another but
right now they're not acting like it and
yes I understand there are much more
important issues facing this country and
facing Congress than impeaching a guy
knowing that you're not going to remove
him from office I get that it doesn't
mean this can't be a side project it
doesn't mean that you can't have
committees already working on the
articles based on what's already on the
table you don't have to wait for the
Muller report we have evidence of
obstruction of justice that's clear as
day we have the campaign finance
violation with the stormy Daniels hush
money payment clear as day those crimes
are ready they're waiting we could do
this right now but you have to do it and
you have to do it because you have to
show the American public that the
executive branch of the federal
government is not above the law
no matter who is sitting in that Oval
Office and by the way you get the added
benefit of running a twenty twenty
presidential campaign against a guy who
was impeached and you also have a bunch
of Republican senators up for
re-election in 2020 that suddenly have
to go explain to their constituents why
they should vote for them even after
they voted to keep a criminal in the
White House sounds like a win-win to me
I'm fair and cousins sitting in for
David Pakman we'll be right back with
more of the David Pakman show today's
program is sponsored in part by Blink
accom slash Pakman if you've not already
heard about blink
it's amazing it's an app for your phone
tablet or web browser and what they do
is they take nonfiction books popular
nonfiction critically acclaimed
nonfiction they condense the book into a
fifteen minute audio book you get all
the most important information and
insights from each book but you can soak
up the entire essence of the book in one
sitting
I've listened to a ton of books on
blinkin recent one is a Robert Rice's
new book the common good
also bunk by Kevin Young useful in
preparing me for the pseudo-science
miniseries that we're producing and if
you are a David Pakman show viewer or
listener you can get a 7 day free trial
by going to blink accom slash Pakman if
you're watching on YouTube use the link
in the video description
after the free trial if you like it you
can get the full access to thousands of
condensed audiobooks for about 5 bucks a
month that's be li NK is t.com /pa ke ma
n